làm nhiệm vụ hệ thống chắc luôn
cực viral với câu chuyện ở nhà có người làm
nhưng vẫn đi làm giúp việc
netizen ngồi soi mà nảy Ra 7.749 kịch bản
tổng tài già nghèo
gần đây
hội mê lướt TikTok dần dần với loạt clip của kênh TikTok
Yến sống ở châu Phi khiển netizen cực hoang mang
vì tâm điểm lại không phải chủ kênh
mà là cô giúp việc trong nhà
dù là người ở
cô vẫn diện váy đẹp có outfit được yến soi Ra giá khá Cao
thần thái lại cực tự tin
rất có gu ăn mặc của người có tiền bonus
mặc dù là giúp việc như ở nhà cô vẫn thuê người làm
chính điều này khiến Yến cũng phải bật cười
không hiểu chuyện gì đang xảy Ra
còn netizen thì khỏi nói
lập tức nhập vai thám tử online
đặt Ra hàng loạt xả thuyết nào là tổng tài giả nghèo
làm nhiệm vụ
hay thậm chí là đi làm vì đam mê chứ không vì tiền
đỉnh điểm là nhiều người còn đòi Yến qua
tận nhà giúp việc để điều tra ngược
biến câu chuyện đời thường thành một series
giải trí đúng nghĩa
dù thực hư Ra SAO
loạt clip này vẫn đang viral mạnh vì quá cuốn
vì vừa đời thường
vừa bí ẩn đủ wow để netizen hóng từng tập